there were just hundreds of snakes in
this temple just waiting for us to show
up what why aren't they biting that guy
this is ridiculous delete
delete delete
what excited you most
about doing this movie honestly like
very much the chance to work with both
of you like that was very gonna take my
answer
i mean
i just told you this ten minutes wow
okay i'm sorry you've got to think of
something new fast um he's giving the
very diplomatic
is genuinely true they're like
so we get along when i like got the
script i knew that you guys were doing
it and they were like you know read this
and say if you respond to it i was like
the level of bad this script would have
to be for me to not want to do it with
you guys involved because it's so high
because you choose bad material in
general like you can consistently choose
i read it
that's what i aim for uh well it's i
think the whole world yeah challenge
really everything he's done
terrible really good yeah so you
basically what excited you was to come
and elevate us
with your englishness how is that what
you took from what i said
i just took what you meant and i said it
out loud right um everybody knows that
that was now you've gone to my real
motivation but yes that was the reason i
just wanted to come on upstairs yeah
you're doing it now chatting
no no you stay over there
what excited you the most
the wig for me i've always i've always
wanted to have long hair i've never had
long hair in my life i just can't do it
and your personality changed when you
walked out it really was uncomfortable
she was her thing she was the wig was
when she came out she was a whole vibe
that was uncomfortable to be around
personally i wasn't ready i just saw it
just
lost me one day
yeah
i walked different it was like a whole i
wasn't ready for it to be fully honest
like it was uh none of us it was a
surprise but a discovery every day it
just wasn't uncovering did you name it
i think we had a bunch of names for it
and i named it sheila
because when sheila was on set she was
hit the fan
okay i guess i'm gonna can i answer this
yeah why not what made me excited about
being in this movie
yes
to be around his englishness was was
exciting
not brutal look
he's elevating us we are elevated
because of his presence how did this
happen no i don't know lots of money um
i don't know i think just the potential
of just laughing
honest to goodness laughing
which i hadn't done in a long time and
hadn't been
don't laugh at me you have to no
because the because the pandemic was a
dry time for laughter dry time yeah
that's actually a really good point just
laughing and
the potential of getting along with
everyone potential but i didn't
was to potentially get along with
everyone
which cast member would you take with
you on a treasure hunt and why honestly
i'm sorry to not name either of you guys
but thomas he plays mustache he plays he
plays monster yes and he is just saying
he plays moustache
[Laughter]
what is the hardest thing about shooting
in the jungle
i have to ask because i didn't do any of
it
the challenge was just i was in the
jumpsuit so i couldn't use the restroom
so i just chose not to drink liquids
which paid off beautifully watching
sandra run in the jungle
with high heels on and a jumpsuit
i gotta say it was nothing short of like
an olympic like event like i still don't
know how you did it i was in like just
normal shoes and i was falling down and
somehow you figured it out if you've
noticed if you zoom into my mouth i was
just praying the whole time please
please god please god
your ankles though are like made of like
unobtainium or something like that yeah
now they are and then it was just like i
would they would say rap and i would
just step off a step and i'd fall yeah
what's the most exotic adventure you
have gone on
daniel
i don't know i was always just
filming it was just like doing a film i
realized
your exotic locations were
were visual effects yeah the ones people
i mean i got to i filmed a movie in the
jungle once called jungle and so i got
uh i got to you know that was exotic
yeah i managed this was it a nice jungle
or was it like it was
it was no it was it was the amazon it
was there it was a real jungle and it
was you know it was rough i'm not made
for
jungle living
but did you look good
um were you sweaty yes i was sort of
glistening and sweaty so that helped and
yeah it's just nice listening to him
this is really nice like i feel like i
need like a books on tape by daniel for
sandy
yeah if you just want to yeah tell me a
book and i can just like you just do
voice notes would you yeah
i won't go jungle even though i have a
jungle one uh i went to iceland and
tried to do a um
a little small glacier crossing and we
got caught in a two-day white out and
almost died so that was a pretty
exhausting yeah it was it was gnarly we
had to get rescued was it beautiful
before
not really we we literally landed and
started like cross-country skiing bedded
down that night we started to go the
next day and then just got hit and it
was and we dug in and that was that was
it wow were you scared
i mean not really because like the
icelandic people are just like the they
were just like emotionless like through
it all so i wasn't i don't think i was
privy to how bad it was getting you're
crying
i was definitely crying i was like man
this is what i wanted to do with my
vacation time
it was once you got out did they say
we've experienced this before we always
get out yeah basically they said they
said that the next stage was to build
ice cage ice caves like where you put
your bag in you like cover it with snow
and then you dig out underneath it and
yeah because we had lost tents and stuff
so it was uh it was getting bad that's
where have you been this exotic
nowhere we're in a pantomic well i guess
that's why we might
the most exotic place i've been i would
say is last night alone in my bed with a
quiet house
and some cheese
so you're basically the actual character
in the movie the cheese was based on my
real life the jumpsuit was based on my
real life many things in this film were
based on my real life i love it so yeah
so last night in bed with my cheese
was it exotic cheese what kind of cheese
was it no it was chilling off it's from
portland
it was the kids little squares they were
individually wrapped and i felt like why
get out the big honker yeah it's
embarrassing
you got to take a massive round of
please with you to the bar thank you
i didn't say it was in the bathroom
so it was in the bed on the bed oh sorry
i thought it was going on the bottom
yeah i said my own image it's in the
movie it's in the movie
that was enough for me
i would take some wine with ice to the
tub but never cheese okay never cheese
in the tub that's dangerous me on that
okay
i will
what's your advice for getting along
with someone on a major trip or a huge
adventure or on a movie set yeah that
too
from them
to them
don't actively be
yeah i feel like that's a pretty good
thing yeah actively you can do it that's
very english that's in my bones like i
can't help that
but you are so not passive aggressive
you are not oh thank you i come from a
long line of passive aggressive english
no that's no we are we're actors that's
how you breed an actor
um but you don't you don't
you're not like that at all not at all
you're just
brilliantly
like you just like he comes prepared
and remembers things that would take
channy and i well at least me we
couldn't do it you guys know you were on
set that's why i was like asking you
about the jungle you were on set every
day of this if i'd come in and you've
been like man radcliff's had 10 days off
and he can't even pick up a cue hardest
thing to do is to come in after having
had 10 days not having been in a rhythm
and knowing that everyone's watching you
with your four pages i'm so generous
with your time and energy too on set
it's wild i was having i was so happy to
be on set because like we were in lovely
hotels but you were still in a hotel so
every time i got to set i was like hey
everyone
how's it going oh you've had a really
tough week i'll try and stifle my energy
no he was he was the loveliest i think
sandra and channing what was it like
shooting um the leeches scene in the
movie that was day two that was day two
day two i literally walked on was like
hi everyone um my name is chan
this is uh my butt and this is going to
be my own set today let's all have a
great shoot all right let's go team
i can definitely say that if you told my
18 year old self that uh that i was
going to be in that situation
[Laughter]
it was good it was great it was i was
just looking up just going yeah this is
happening this is like your book we're
on the love more and dash adventure
right now i'm gonna help you out a
little bit let's go what are you doing
don't do that come on get out of there
this is not a romance novel jungles eat
people like us what is that get it off
i can feel them suckers
on me
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah they're just sucking on my butt
like a big old jamba juice
you